c'est en 2017 que les téléspectateurs de
TF1 découvrent Dylan Thierry dans le jeu
d'aventure Koh-Lanta parfois je viendrai
dans la forêt avec un jogging parce
qu'en short ça c'est trop dangereux mais
depuis qu'il a accédé à une certaine
notoriété l'influenceur fait
régulièrement polémique après avoir été
accusé d'escroquerie envers ses abonnés
et d'avoir détourné des fonds
le nom de l'ancien candidat de
télé-réalité vient de resurgir cette
semaine dans une autre affaire à travers
des audio relayées sur internet et dans
lesquels on entendrait Dylan Cyrus
exprimait l'homme serait accusé d'avoir
voulu monter un réseau proxénète via une
plateforme en ligne de contenu érotique
et d'avoir imaginé un trafic d'enfant à
Madagascar je suis quelqu'un qui est
toujours dans des sauces donc c'est des
tismes trafic d'enfants alors que se
passe-t-il autour du candidat de
téléréalité Dylan Thierry alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette histoire
merci ginda d'être avec nous est-ce que
vous nous raconter cette affaire parce
que j'ai rien compris oui et après je
parlerai pour savoir si c'est que cette
histoire aussi est-ce que je peux déjà
vous embrouiller un petit peu Cyril non
merci
je m'appelle Jean da voilà et alors
comment je vous ai appelé
alors Dylan
vous l'avez sans doute connu sur
Koh-Lanta ensuite il a fait d'autres
émissions comme les princes de l'amour
les apprentis aventuriers et plein de
non recommencez pas avec vous les ma
Cyril
etc et c'est vrai que là il est dans une
grosse sauce comme on dit une très
grosse
voilà il y en aise il y a un collectif
il y a un collectif sur Twitter le
collectif AVI il y a Booba aussi il y a
Sandra son ancien agent qui ont sorti
des petits zodios où on l'entend dire
des choses assez graves
d'abord il y a une première histoire
apparemment où il voudrait mettre en
place un système où il comment dire il
ferait faire des mimes vous connaissez
tous c'est c'est voilà des photos de
chats
il y a une application qui s'appelle
des photos de charme exactement et son
but c'était de recruter des jeunes
femmes pour faire des photos de charme
et se prendre une commission dessus et
un peu plus grave il y a un autre audio
où bah on l'entend parler là et pour le
coup c'est très très grave
Dylan il a fait beaucoup d'actions
humanitaires au Sénégal à gascar ou
encore en Palestine et il y a une
influenceuse qui s'appelle jazz que vous
connaissez sans doute qui fait partie de
la DLC family
sa sœur
c'est comment elle s'appelle oui
exactement
et jazz avait pour projet
c'est son vrai prénom
donc jazz a pour projet depuis longtemps
d'adopter un enfant voilà sauf que elle
a demandé conseil à Dylan de par ses
actions humanitaires et on entend dans
un autre jour Dylan parler à cette
fameuse Sandra donc qui est son ancien
agent dire
jazz je vais lui proposer en gros je
vais lui proposer
de lui envoyer de lui récupérer un
enfant dans un pays voilà clairement ce
qu'il dit dans ces audios pour être
totalement factuel c'est je vais prendre
le passeport d'une fillette d'un ami à
moi qui est noir une petite fille noire
voilà je vais partir à Madagascar ou
dans un pays je vais revenir avec une
petite fille noire avec le passeport
bien évidemment qui ne lui
appartiendrait pas et dans ce cas là je
le proposerai à quelqu'un en échange
d'une certaine somme d'argent
la suite de nombreuses tentatives
d'intimidation de la part d'une de ses
anciennes collaboratrices
[Musique]
et tout ça j'ai l'habitude je connais
d'ici une semaine on n'entend plus
parler parce qu'encore une fois il y a
pas d'actes il y a des paroles qui sont
choquantes mais il y a pas d'acte mais
c'est vrai que parfois je parle mal ça
c'est vrai surtout quand je suis en
intimité tu vois avec mon agent je me
confiais je parle avec elle le corps
ouvert et en fait c'est la même personne
qui a tourné le moindre faux pas pour te
trahir Sandra Sandra
osé quand même partager ce note vocale
un certain moment j'ai été bâtard mais
jamais j'aurais mis alors j'ai ton
adresse j'ai ton nom de famille
jamais j'aurais sorti ça sur la place
publique et elle sans scrupule elle
envoie des notes vocales comme ça à ceux
qui veulent me faire voilà alors donc il
a répondu Gilles Verdez est-ce que c'est
quoi cette affaire à cette affaire elle
est compliquée parce que c'est vrai que
son image était
brouillé ou sulfureuse comme on veut
mais là si c'était avéré il y a la
présomption d'innocence mais si c'est
avéré Cyril il y a des députés qui sont
qui se sont saisis du dossier on
passerait à un autre cap alors moi je
vais vous dire en toute transparence si
vous voulez parce que c'est quoi
l'histoire exactement parce que alors
non en fait c'est que en fait toi tu
devais écrire un livre avec Dylan
exactement
mai 2022 mais il est venu de voir quoi
la suite de l'émission bah moi ce qui
m'intéressait chez lui c'était surtout
de parler de sa vie et de l'islam
puisqu'il est converti voilà donc ça
m'intéressait de parler de ça avec lui
donc du coup on a trouvé des des
points d'intérêt de discussion et il y a
une décision d'écrire un livre qui
aujourd'hui je le précise tout de suite
et suspendu il n'y a pas de date de
parution arrêté mais vous avez un
éditeur ou pas encore il y avait un
éditeur le livre c'était
l'autobiographie de Dylan Thierry et moi
je l'interview ouvert c'était écrit à la
première personne pardon c'est lui qui
est venu vous voir non c'est moi qui à
la suite de ces passages dans l'émission
lui est dit ça m'intéresserait de faire
quelque chose autour de l'islam
notamment et de raconter ta ville au
projet est venu comme ça et donc on a
fait des interviews au téléphone
puisqu'il est à Dubaï plusieurs sessions
d'interview à la première personne et
moi tout ce qu'il me disait c'est pas
forcément du tout que je cautionne mais
je lui posais des questions je
l'interviewé pour qu'il raconte sa vie
alors dans le livre on esquivait aucune
polémique toutes les polémiques qui sont
autour des cagnottes vous savez on a
parlé de lui pour les cagnottes lors de
voyage humanitaires raconte-nous parce
que nous on est on comprend rien
que les mecs là vous vous avez
l'impression que tout le monde est dans
l'histoire on a vu deux trucs passer sur
les réseaux on en a rien à carrer donc
beaucoup de mariage humanitaires merci à
chaque fois il demande qui est des
cagnottes vous savez les fameuses
cagnottes il a été quoi des cagnotte
pour financer un voyage humain pour
aider des gens voilà donc des gens sont
émus une série en disant à quoi est
destiné l'argent donc moi je lui faisais
réagir sur tout ça ce que je précise
très nettement c'est que tous les audio
là dont tu parlais donc vous parliez qui
viennent de sortir je n'étais aucunement
au courant toutes ces pratiques
potentiellement illégales je ne
connaissais pas t'aurais arrêté le livre
sans doute voilà on avait parlé on avait
parlé de l'adoption parce que lui-même
est dans un process d'adoption donc il a
déjà parlé à Madagascar on en avait
parlé et moi tant avec son ancienne
agente Sandra qu'avec lui je posais des
questions jamais même vérifier si un
Madagascar on pouvait adopter comme ça
donc tout ça on en parlait
pour lui absolument il voulait adopter
un enfant ça je le dis clairement il
m'en avait parlé c'était prévu dans le
livre voilà et donc je lui demandais
mais est-ce que super bien fait toutes
les formalités comment ça s'est passé
donc voilà on est ce qui veut rien mais
tout ce qui s'est passé là c'est autre
chose et ça j'ignorais mais sauf que
pardon j'ai mais tu t'écris un livre
avec quelqu'un tu sais bien tu poses des
bonnes questions et te répond mais tu
prends ses réponses pour des réponses tu
tu enquêtes pas si le mec il suffit ok
pas du tout sur ce qui te réponds
tout ça tu veux que tu regrettes pas du
tout sur un personnage je lui pose des
questions je voyais avec son agent où on
en est il répond sur le bouquin pardon
il répond et tu sors le bouquin tu
vérifies pas du tout le bouquin ne sort
pas justement je comprends et c'est vrai
qu'avec l'éditeur et avec Dylan
tripartite on s'est dit c'est pas le bon
moment pour sortir un livre Cyril
il pense qu'il n'a rien à se reprocher
comme dans cette vidéo pourquoi ils font
pas et pourquoi il fait pas le livre que
je lui demande vraiment
on était plutôt David de reporter
d'attendre pour l'instant de voir ce qui
va se passer on peut pas mettre Gilles
dans la sauce comme ça
et moi ce qui me gêne aujourd'hui c'est
que la justice elle se fait pas sur
Twitter je suis désolé aujourd'hui on
mélange
vraiment ce qui s'est passé parce que
c'est devenu insupportable on a trouvé
on a le droit de trouver des audio les
accusations sont très graves mais j'en
ai marre moi des tweets avec les mots
justement moi j'en ai marre des des
tweets avec des audios de 3 secondes une
conversation c'est pas qui a parlé avec
la raison ça a des conséquences légales
sur quelqu'un qui a un petit peu
sulfureux bah tu te dois de vérifier par
deux trois autres sources
pas forcément un mec tu peux interviewer
un criminel un mec qui a commis des
dessins cités supportable aussi
les réseaux moi je pense que moi je vais
fermer le mien j'en peux plus les gens
parlent je parle ils savent rien
je vois des infos sur vous des fois
n'importe quoi les deux dernières
semaines je te jure que je te jure ça
m'a fait la peine juste pour ma fille du
Monoprix qui me voyait tout le temps et
elle fait comme ça mais c'est
même sur nous là on a eu engueulade ils
peuvent pas s'attaquer du racisme
l'homophobie moi je suis parti faire une
dépression je ne sais pas pourquoi en
Espagne
quelqu'un de ma famille est morte au
bout d'un moment tu dis ça allez vous
faire [__] quoi
il se répondent ils se connaissent pas
et il se répondent sur des gens qui se
connaissent pas d'un sujet qui
connaissent pas non mais c'est ça
continue
on m'envoie des trucs des fois [__] et
le pire c'est que la presse reprend mais
c'est ça exactement
pixelisé de snapchat il y a 3 ans il
faut une page comme ça dans la presse
nationale et c'est ça qui fait qu'après
on va en parler dans tous les bien sûr
publics sur moi les vraies raisons de
ton absence de semaine je te jure que
c'est vrai sur ma vie je n'ai pas eu un
appel même pas un tout petit ou un texto
de la journaliste un tout petit voir si
je lui ment non ils écrivent ils
appellent mais ils font même plus
semblant de d'appeler ou quoi
juste par rapport à Dylan effectivement
bon là Gilles tu viens de tu viens de le
dire tu as commencé cette ce livre
c'était l'année dernière à cette à cette
époque là il y avait pas encore toutes
les casseroles de Dylan c'est voilà
c'est juste pour pour préciser moi la
première par exemple sur sur les
missions dans laquelle je travaille on a
déjà évoqué le cas de Dylan j'ai déjà
pris même position et la défense de
Dylan en me disant mais attendez on voit
un influenceur là où on tape beaucoup
sur les influenceurs là pour une fois on
voit un influenceur qui va à l'étranger
faire de l'humanitaire j'ai trouvé ça
magnifique et j'étais la première à la
première à le dire sauf qu'effectivement
derrière et bah il y a plein de choses
qui se qui se sont dévoilées à savoir où
est passé les cagnottes où est passé
l'argent de ces fameuses cagnottes qu'en
a-t-il fait de c'est de ces cagnottes et
c'est quelqu'un qui prône justement la
religion donc on a tendance à vouloir
beaucoup lui faire confiance parce qu'il
s'est accaparé une certaine communauté
parce qu'il parle beaucoup de de
religion mais là pardon on peut dire ce
qu'on veut moi je suis la première à
faire un mea culpa là-dessus là on parle
de trade d'enfants
le procureur a été saisi on va voir ce
qui va dire et on verra ce que veut dire
le procureur on se croira le procureur
voilà pour l'instant la lumière avec
exactement
moi je vois comme il a dit il y a tout
le monde qui qui s'enflamme on verra et
on en saura plus qu'on le procureur aura
voilà nous on dira ce qui ce qui donne
ce qui est Dylan n'est pas français il
est Luxembourg et il vit à Dubaï donc
j'aimerais bien savoir comment ça va
comment ça va se dérouler parce
qu'effectivement il y a le les députés
Arthur de la porte et Stéphane vogeta
qui ont saisi le procureur de la
République pour les soupçons de trafic
d'enfants mais on va on va juger
on va voir en tout cas ce qu'elle fait
oui est-ce qu'il faut voir c'est les
intentions aussi de ceux qui dénoncent
ça c'est pas de dénoncer le trafic
d'enfant exactement c'est de mettre un
gars dans la sauce et je suis désolé des
sujets aussi graves aussi importants je
vais passer avec un tweet une petite
vidéo pixelisée et trois smiley qui
pleure comme c'était rigolo c'est
extrêmement grave et là pour le coup il
faut laisser la justice s'en occuper et
si tu es témoin de ça que tu as des
infos va avoir la police ne mets pas les
gens dans des sauces sur Twitter
n'importe comment parce que ça peut
vraiment mettre des gens en danger et
des vies en danger donc il faut faire
gaffe avec ça c'est un sujet important
c'est un sujet grave et voilà c'est
mérite d'être traité autre part que sur
les réseaux